eric zemmour a le droit de s'exprimer
dans les médias il en a d'autant plus le
droit qui représente un courant d'idées
dans lequel se reconnaissent beaucoup de
français ce dont témoignent les
audiences que font ces les émissions
alors il ya un x 3 la case avec
christina et les ventes et les ventes de
ses livres de lampard 6 6 2 et demi par
sera le premier soir par deux 2 2 dans
le premier soir de approuvé au bon sinon
bessard 2-2 et demi par trois le premier
soir par deux et demi le reste c kon les
audiences sont énormes et ce dont
témoigne aussi les ventes de ses livres
et après à partir de là il ya deux
principes il peut s'exprimer mais
évidemment il doit répondre de ses
propos devant les tribunaux si on estime
qu'il a franchi les limites de la loi et
deuxièmement en effet il doit avoir en
face de lui un contradicteur et non pas
je sais pas ce qui a pris aux dirigeants
de lci un moment d'égarement de diffuser
juste sans discours où il a pu
s'exprimer en roue libre pendant une
demi heure ça je trouve que ce n'est pas
admissible
alors on a on a les extrêmes là j'ai
vraiment jamais le csa a été saisi et le
csa leurs amis je crois qu'ils ont mis
en garde
une mise en garde c'est donc nous on
prendra maintenant d'euros et un oeil à
eric zemmour qu'il fait pour dix minutes
l'apologie une demi heure c'est vrai
l'apologie de l'islamophobie du racisme
et et prennent un avertissement à voter
en tout cas si ces deux conditions sont
réunies à savoir y répondre de ses
propos devant les instances légitimes ça
peut être le csa peut être les tribunaux
et il ya un contradicteur
je ne vois pas qui peut le bannir des
médias on va on va voir cet extrait qui
a fait énormément parler rien nous avons
l'embarras du choix dans les années 30
les auteurs les plus lucides qui
dénonçait le danger allemand comparait
le nazisme à l'islam oui l'islam
il disait l'islam et personne ne leur
reprocher de stigmatiser l'islam à la
limite beaucoup trouvaient qu'ils
exagèrent est un petit peu bien sûr
disait-il le nazisme est parfois un peu
raide et intolérant mais de là à
comparer à l'islam
alors voilà ça eu énormément choqué
c'est normal c'est vrai que c'est passé
comme ça on direct sur une chaîne d'info
tranquillement voilà ça pour moi c'est
serré le missile vous l'y voit là oui ça
c'est inadmissible responsabiliser
rajoute deux petites choses je ne
reviendrai jamais sur l'amitié que je
porte à zemmour à titre personnel c'est
un ami c'est un ami avec lequel j'ai des
désaccords de plus en plus profond et de
plus en plus fréquents j'ai l'honnêteté
de le dire il ya des tas de gens qui
cachent dans amitié quand ils sont pas
du même avis politique moi je ne cache
rien en revanche je lui dis sur les
plateaux de télévision je lui dis aussi
à titre privé je trouve que depuis
quelques temps il déconne et là on a
passé le point sur lequel il est le plus
jeune du nazisme est hilare j'ai trouvé
ça inadmissible et il a trouvé ça
inqualifiable voilà et là il n'y a pas
de discussion peut-être que il a pressé
il a pris de mise en garde à vue il a
été mis en garde attention eric faucheux
pas recommencer 1
est-ce que vous et moi je sais que vous
êtes à pau bon je suis rien contre le
css à l'ena il a aussi saisi là je me
sens bien sur wii mais bien sûr c'est
une mise en garde attention à ne leur
fait plus parce que c'est bourrin voilà
c'est une rigolade de sinndar cas ils
sont devenus fous aussi